[Musik]
heute ist ein großer freudentag für die
melker pioniere wir haben das so
genannte erweiterungsgebiet nach elf
jahren erhalten und eröffnet wir können
jetzt endlich die millionenschweren
wenig geräte ordentlich gepflegt
instandgesetzt und untergestellt werden
und das erhöht die einsatzbereitschaft
des pinot bei uns deutlich die pioniere
sind in den letzten jahren vorrangig bei
hochwässern eingesetzt wesen aber auch
bei der schneekatastrophe am hochkar zu
beginn dieses jahres internationalität
gesehen war mein job beim feldlager bei
aber auch beim straßenbau in ungarn oder
auch beim uhren abgingen egal wichtig
hat das treffe die melker pioniere sind
immer bereit
[Musik]